aliza un an depuis ce dimanche la petite
ukrainienne vient de faire ses premiers
pas mais en france avec sa maman sa
tante et ses cousines elle vit
aujourd'hui à voisins le bretonneux
dans le fait d'être dans cette maison ça
nous aide énormément de nous adapter de
nous changer les idées d'oublier un peu
le cauchemar qui se passe en ukraine on
reprend la vie on apprend le français
ont fait connaissance avec les voisins
on communique avec des gens
un quotidien où la peinture et la
musique ont repris leur place daria une
amie installé à saint quentin en
yvelines depuis plusieurs années est là
pour traduire et les accompagner ou même
s'ils sont déjà bien installés je
continue quand même un homme occupé
d'elle parce que je comprends très bien
que ce que c'est d'être dans un pays
dont la langue on parle pas ça peut être
difficile il ya beaucoup des questions
administratives médicales
pour les écoles pour les activités et
ses organisations demandent qu dead et
si je peux la porte à porte daria est
aussi un lien pour la famille d'oksana
et anastasia partie de czerny flux 8
mars avec leur petite fille elles sont
aussi hébergé sur voisins le bretonneux
elle essaye de panser leurs plaies le
mari d'anastasia est mort dans leur
fuite il avait 43 ans et a été abattu
par un sniper près de kiev les trois
femmes sont menacées par des soldats les
proches d'oksana sont encore en ukraine
à marioupol non opioïde l'homme le plus
important pour nous c'est qu'il n'y ait
pas d'avion au-dessus de nous qui
lancent des bombes la vie reprend des
couleurs parce que quand on partait de
notre ville de notre pays on avait
l'impression qu'il n'y avait plus de
couleurs que tout était en noir et blanc
c'était extrêmement triste et douloureux
l'accueil de ces deux familles a été
rendue possible par les équipes
municipales de voisins-le-bretonneux la
mairie a mise à disposition de maison de
quatre pièces de fonction une chaîne de
solidarité s'est ensuite développée il a
fallu meubler les maisons et nous avons
a fait appel à toutes les bonnes
volontés un bel landes
bel élan de solidarité
bon carrefour market qui a mis à
disposition tout le matériel qu'on en a
besoin dans une maison micron de
cafetière planche à repasser enfin voilà
tous ces petits détails le promoteur
vinci immobilier qui a donné des frigos
et des des machines à laver le linge on
nous avons galère un bailleur social qui
nous a fourni des meubles les enfants
ont été scolarisés dans des
établissements heavy noyau beaux-arts à
versailles des bons alimentaires du ccas
sont mises à leur disposition ainsi
qu'un appel aux dons la commune
accompagne aussi d'autres réfugiés
accueillis chez des administrés